monsieur le Président je ne voulais
surtout pas qu'on se quitte dans
quelques minutes après l'arrêt de cette
séance sans remercier les oppositions au
Sénat d'avoir cité tant de fois mon nom
et franchement je n'en attendais pas
tant et je pense que je n'en mérite pas
tant alors merci mes chers collègues
d'avoir donné un peu de notoriété au nom
que vous avez fait résonner dans cette
émission maintenant sur le fond monsieur
le Président puisqu'il faut que je fasse
une explication de votre bien-sûr nous
n'allons pas voter ses amendements et
nous voterons l'article 1 puisque nous
sommes favorables à la fermeture de ces
régimes spéciaux et nous sommes
favorables à une accélération et à une
convergence en 2040 pourquoi est-ce que
l'amendement que je présenterai tout à
l'heure a été placé en seconde partie
pas par un calcul calendaire calcule que
vous faites vous-même calcul que vous
faites vous-même c'est tout simplement
que il représente une modification du
régime de versement de prestations et il
appartient de le placer à la seconde
partie au moment de la partie des
dépenses si nous voulons l'extinction en
tout cas la fermeture de ces régimes
spéciaux c'est précisément lance
Rossignol parce que nous pensons que ils
abîment en quelque sorte le commun il
concourt à l'archipelisation comment
expliquer aux Français que pour des
mêmes travaux pour la même pénibilité
vous vous trouvez ici sur Paris vous
partez à 52 ans et vous vous trouvez
ailleurs et vous partez 10 ans plus tard
ça n'est pas compréhensible évidemment
chers Fabien gay il y a pas de il y a
pas de lien entre la souveraineté que
nous aimons que nous voulons vous et moi
promouvoir énergétique et les régimes
spéciaux voilà ce que je voulais vous
dire et sur désormais aussi une mise au
point puisque vous nous reprochez de ne
pas participer au débat nous y
participerons pour les amendements bien
entendu que nous voulons défendre pour
lesquelles nous voulons enrichir le
texte simplement
il n'y a pas de silence
ne nous exprimons très régulièrement par
la voix de nous rapporteurs de nous
rapporteurs merci président ce que je
voudrais terminer pour dire aussi que
nous ne tomberons pas dans le piège que
vous nous demandez vous voulez faire de
l'obstruction vous voulez faire de
l'ostruction et nous pas nous voulons
examiner l'ensemble du texte et donc
nous réservons notre temps de parole
pour défendre nos positions nos
propositions
madame Cohen
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]